tenemos este problema muestra que siendo
un triángulo el otro centro y el centro
y d coinciden entonces el triángulo
equilátero va entonces el [ __ ] centro y
el centro y d coinciden y como
recordatorio el otro centro es donde se
intersectan las alturas de un triángulo
y el centro hoy de es donde se
intersectan las medianas entonces aquí
en la figura podemos suponer que este
punto de aquí es [ __ ] centro y centro y
d y por lo tanto estas tres rectas son
alturas y medianas déjame pasar esa
información a ver cómo son alturas
entonces llegan a los lados con ángulos
rectos con ángulos de 90 grados entonces
todos estos ángulos son de de 90 grados
también tenemos por acá 90 grados y 90
grados 90 grados pero además como este
punto es el centro y d tenemos que las
tres son medianas así llegan a los
puntos medios del lado opuesto y por lo
tanto este segmento es igual a este de
acá también tenemos que este segmento es
igual a este de acá y finalmente tenemos
que este segmento
es igual a este de acá muy bien entonces
pasan todavía más cosas padres verdad
porque estas rectas son perpendiculares
y llegan al punto medio entonces además
de ser medianas y alturas también son
media tristes y por lo tanto este punto
de acá también es el círculo centro del
triángulo pero bueno
fuera de estas cosas padres que pasan
vamos a enfocarnos en mostrar que el
triángulo equilátero vale para eso
déjame ponerle el nombre a los puntos
involucrados para poder referirme a
ellos estoy acá va a ser de por aquí va
a estar y por aquí va a estar
efe y al centro y de [ __ ] centro le voy
a llamar g bueno lo primero que vamos a
hacer es comparar los triángulos a gf el
triángulo
efe
efe con el triángulo
notemos que ya tienen varias cosas en
común tienen
efe efe o sea este lado es igual a este
tienen f g igual a sí mismo entonces es
este lado es igual a este lado visto en
cada uno de los triángulos y además
tienen el ángulo entre esos dos lados
correspondientes igual porque es un
ángulo de 90 grados entonces tenemos que
estos dos triángulos son congruentes por
el criterio lado ángulo lado lo voy a
poner por aquí estos dos de acá son
congruentes congruentes
por el criterio lado ángulo plano muy
bien y como son congruentes tienen otras
partes correspondientes en común ahorita
las marcamos déjame déjame ver otros
triángulos ahora vámonos al eje de con
el cgd es exactamente la misma idea una
vez más tenemos este lado este ángulo y
este lado iguales a este lado este
ángulo y este lado entonces también son
triángulos congruentes lo voy a poner
por aquí tenemos que el triángulo
triángulo eje d
es congruente al triángulo cgd el
triángulo ce
y también es por el criterio lado ángulo
lado y lo mismo sucede con estos dos de
acá verdad también tenemos también
tenemos lo voy a poner en morado que el
triángulo cgb y el triángulo c que ve es
congruente
se ve al bebé es congruente al triángulo
a gm bueno con esto deberíamos de poder
trabajar bastante la información que
tenemos en la figura déjame marcar este
ángulo de acá como un ángulo azul él efe
ag entonces éste lo voy a poner como
ángulo azul y este de acá este de aquí
lo voy a poner con un ángulo pues
digamos amarillo vale entonces ahí
tenemos ángulo amarillo bueno como los
triángulos
fg son congruentes entonces este ángulo
de acá el ángulo en a es igual al ángulo
en déjame marcarlo y estoy aquí está
azul va pero además este ángulo es igual
a este de acá o sea el eje a es
congruente al fg y entonces éste sería
igual este de acá vamos a seguir pasando
ángulos pero ahora no vamos a usar las
congruencia si no vamos a usar que éste
es opuesto por el vértice a este de acá
entonces el ángulo egea y el de gc esos
dos ángulos son congruentes
tenemos que este ángulo es también lo
mismo que el amarillo de acá y de manera
similar como estos dos son son
triángulos congruentes tenemos que este
también es igual al amarillo este cruza
a través del vértice por acá y este
cruza a través del vértice por acá vale
entonces observa que estos seis ángulos
que quedaron aquí en el centro
digamos ángulos internos todos miden lo
mismo todos estos ángulos amarillos
miden lo mismo vale pero ahora vamos a
ver qué sucede con los otros ángulos de
estos triángulos pequeños observa que
este triángulo
ya tiene un ángulo recto y un ángulo
amarillo pero lo mismo sucede con el de
eje también tiene un triángulo recto y
un ángulo amarillo entonces el ángulo
azulito es lo que falta para que azul
más amarillo más verde sumen 180 grados
y por lo tanto este de acá también tiene
que ser azul vale este de aquí es azul
este de aquí también es azul este de
aquí es azul vaya a lo que estoy
diciendo es que si en un triángulo ya
conocemos dos de los ángulos entonces el
tercero queda totalmente determinado
como en esos seis triángulos
todos tienen el verde o sea el recto y
el amarillo entonces también deben de
tener a la suya entonces azul azul azul
azul azul y este acá también es azul va
pero observa entonces con estos ángulos
azulitos podemos concluir lo siguiente
vamos a ver ahora el ángulo que hace
tenemos que el ángulo ángulo hace que
hace está conformado por dos ángulos
azulitos entonces es congruente al
ángulo hace
hace y porque también son dos ángulos
azulitos y s de ahí es congruente al
ángulo c
congruente al ángulo
y a
y listo conseguimos un triángulo en el
cual los tres ángulos en los vértices
son iguales y por lo tanto los tres
deben de ser iguales a 60 grados de esta
forma mostramos que si el otro centro y
el centro debe coincidir en entonces los
tres ángulos del triángulo son iguales y
como ya platicamos antes esto es
suficiente para asegurar que los tres
lados del triángulo son iguales